[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos del clima extremo que se
registra en varias partes del mundo
desde temperaturas de 49 grados en
canadá y los incendios en la costa de
este norteamericana las inundaciones en
europa y asia
para ello nos acompaña raúl garcía él es
director legislativo de comunidades
saludables de la ong ambiental
pérez justice señor garcía gracias por
estar aquí con nosotros en france 24 le
pregunto que está provocando este clima
extremo en todo el mundo
bueno primero gracias por la invitación
a la verdad lo que estamos viendo es el
cambio climático la crisis climática que
estamos viviendo es realmente un
problema muy grande que nos está
costando acre cientos de miles de acres
en el noroeste en el norte noroeste de
eeuu y desgraciadamente estamos viviendo
las consecuencias de una contaminación
que se viene dando desde el último siglo
y medio ahora raúl hable más
específicamente esos incendios en la
costa oeste de norteamérica los
incendios en canadá son principalmente
espontáneos mientras que en eeuu algunos
y la mayoría son provocados cuál es la
responsabilidad de la sociedad en este
asunto
creo que es ver nuestros sistemas de
energía nuestros sistemas de transporte
y ver cómo estamos aportando a este tipo
de déficits tenemos mucha contaminación
saliendo de carbono de nuestros carros
de nuestras plantas de energía y demás
entonces aparte del incendio que les
está causando no es solamente eso pero
tenemos que ver la macro crisis que
estamos viviendo eso significa el
cambiar nuestro consumo de energía a
energía renovable y limpia y también
tener en cuenta que nosotros estamos
aportando con esa contaminación hacer
que condiciones en el suelo sean más
propensas a causar este tipo de
incendios ahora en cuanto a las
inundaciones y las lluvias intensas en
europa minas ya está el cambio climático
detrás de todo esto
si definitivamente el cambio climático
sabemos que causa tormentas más fuertes
de casos que hace que ríos lleven agua
que antes o cantidades de agua que antes
no llevaban y todo esto se está causando
de una manera que no estamos preparados
para lidiar con ella en estos momentos
estamos perdiendo tiempo al seguir
usando este tipo de energías sucias y
definitivamente lo estamos viendo por
todo el mundo ya sean tormentas más
fuertes en el caribe con huracanes o
inundaciones en europa o fuegos
forestales en el noroeste eeuu y canadá
raúl quiero volver a ese punto de
nuestro consumo de energía como evalúa
la situación actual en cuanto al
cumplimiento de los compromisos de cara
a reducir estas emisiones globales de
acuerdo al acuerdo de parís
creo que estamos perdiendo mucho tiempo
creo que tenemos que ser más drásticos y
mucho más agresivos en este cambio que
se tiene que hacer ya estamos viviendo
las consecuencias y la verdad lo que
estamos tratando de hacer en estos
momentos es mitigar la crisis que ya
estamos viviendo entonces creo que hay
muchos buenos deseos pero todo estos
todos los deseos se tienen que convertir
en realidad eso significa que tenemos
que cambiar nuestra política de energía
nuestra política de tránsito de usar
combustibles fósiles muy sucios a
cambiar a energías renovables y
principalmente en las comunidades que lo
necesitan más las comunidades que son
más afectadas por esta crisis temática
le pregunto además cuáles son los puntos
o las acciones puntuales que los
responsables de tomar estas decisiones
de los países deben tomar para
contrarrestar esta situación además de
las que ya no nos nombraba
tenemos que dejar de invertir en
energías sucias todo lo que estamos
viendo en términos de inversiones en
oleoductos
o más hoyos petroleros o lo que sea de
ese tipo de energía tenemos que
cambiarla por por agua por por viento
por energía solar y eso tiene que tiene
que llevar una inversión fuerte tiene
que ser radical estamos hablando de de
cientos de miles de millones de dólares
que se tienen que invertir para que
nuestras comunidades tengan acceso a
esta a esta energía más limpia y que no
tengan que depender de una industria
petrolera muy sucia y
y desgraciadamente nos deja con estas
consecuencias muy malas para todo para
todo el mundo pues raúl esperemos que
entonces ya tomemos las acciones
necesarias para contrarrestar todo este
cambio climático y el desastre que
estamos viendo alrededor del mundo un
placer conversar contigo en esta edición
de cinco minutos con aquí en france 24
ustedes saben gracias continuar con
nosotros es muy buen día
[Música]